[Music]
a scorching hot never-ending day on one
side and a permanent frozen knight on
the other
this is what our planet would be like if
it was tidally locked to the sun
how would your life be different on this
earth
where would you actually be able to
survive
what would happen to your sense of time
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was always facing
the sun
earth makes one full rotation on its
axis every 24 hours
and every 365 days we complete our orbit
around the sun
this is what gives us our sunrises
sunsets and changes of season
if the speed of this rotation and
revolution were the same
then the earth would be tidally locked
this means that one side of the planet
would always be facing the sun
and the other would face away shrouded
in perpetual darkness
this is why you can only see one side of
the moon
it's tidally locked to the earth
you should enjoy that nighttime view
while you still have it
depending on what side of the planet
you're on
you may never see the moon or stars
ever again
with one side of the planet facing the
wrath of the sun and the other facing
the darkness of space
your best odds for survival would be to
live somewhere between the two
welcome to the twilight zone
this thin strip of land that borders
both day and night is also called the
terminator line
it would possibly be the only area on a
tidally locked earth
where things are not too hot and
not too cold
just like our solar system's goldilocks
zone
the width of the terminator line would
likely be exactly the same as it is
today
about 60 kilometers
the only difference is that instead of
moving across the planet every day as it
rotates
this strip would be permanent
if this area of never-ending dusk and
dawn were the only place for humans to
live
things would be quite crowded
it would mean everyone would squeeze
into a space as large as argentina or 25
of the united states
that is if you got lucky and the entire
strip was made of land and not water
whether anywhere outside of this zone is
habitable would depend on how well heat
could be transported around the planet
if there are strong enough jet winds on
each hemisphere they could move hot air
from one side and cold air to the other
with an atmosphere as thick as ours
these winds could take the scorching
daytime side down a few notches
and you'd be thankful for every cloud
providing some temporary shade from the
sun
this hemisphere could end up resembling
the temperatures of earth's current
tropical regions
life would be challenging on our planet
you know even with a temperature
difference as small as 10 degrees
celsius between each side
there would be a big pressure difference
that could turn these once helpful jet
winds into super powerful destructive
ones
one of the things you'd find hardest to
get your hands on would be liquid water
for this to be the case areas of the
daytime side would need to have a milder
climate
even with this it may not be enough to
sustain everyone and on the dark side
the water would likely freeze to ice
with such an extreme temperature
variation you could see water molecules
going through a vicious cycle
on the daytime side the intense heat
could lead to evaporation
then they could drift over to the dark
side form back into clouds and return to
the daytime side where the process would
be repeated all over again
so you'd have to get creative
you could develop some kind of mining
and transport operation to take ice from
the cold side and melt it
or you could convert water vapor from
the day side into liquid water
one thing you'd have enough of is solar
power
on the sunny side of the planet your
supply would be endless
you'd just have to make sure your solar
panels could withstand the intense heat
the solar panels already don't work
properly in some of the hotter places in
the world
temperatures as high as 50 degrees
celsius plus a large buildup of dust
could make these panels 50 percent less
effective
but you could use the blazing
temperatures themselves as a way to
generate electricity
you'd need what's called thermoelectric
technology
by placing one end of the device on the
hot side of the planet and the other on
the cold side you could get free
electricity simply from the temperature
difference
there's a chance this wouldn't give you
much to work with though
that's because these thermoelectric
devices are usually only used for things
that don't demand a ton of power
so
you could back up your batteries or keep
your mini fridge cool
trying to figure out how and where you
could live outside the twilight zone
would be tough
on the hot side you could be dealing
with rocks melting around you
you wouldn't be able to build a house on
a permanent magma ocean
and the cold side would make surface
living nearly impossible
instead you could live deep underground
there you'd enjoy the warmth of
geothermal heating
closer to the twilight zone you could
get by in heavily insulated houses
you'd just need to crank up the air
conditioner electric radiator or
geothermal furnace
if you wanted to take more drastic
measures to cool down the hot side of
the planet you could try to block out
the sun
and no i don't mean with a giant shade
you could borrow a trick from the 1991
volcanic eruption of mount pinatubo in
the philippines
this released so much sulfur dioxide
into the stratosphere that it cooled the
entire planet down by 0.5 degrees
celsius
for global warming this could be a
helpful solution but it wouldn't be
quite enough to cool down the entire hot
side of the planet
you'd also need to come up with some new
ways to support plant life
if they didn't freeze first plants
wouldn't be able to perform
photosynthesis on earth's dark side
on the light side
most plants would be cooked within hours
you'd need to supply them with
artificial sunlight
along the terminator line you'd be able
to harvest a few plants that don't need
much light like wheat grass and white
asparagus
or you could go the fungus root with
different varieties of mushrooms
and if all this weren't enough already
the sky
would never change
you need to find a new way to measure
hours days and months
and if you didn't settle on the dark
side of the earth
you'd never see much of the night sky
ever again
no moon no stars and no planets to dream
about
a few generations down the line you
could find that humans have forgotten
about the rest of the solar system or
universe entirely
but hey things could be worse
instead of spinning very slowly earth
could be spinning at the speed of light
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you